thanks to brilliant for helping support
this episode
hey crazies you've probably heard of
length contraction and time dilation
before
it's the idea that your length shrinks
and your time slows
the faster you move but it's not just an
idea
it's real it's measurable we've tested
it
we'll spend this entire video discussing
how and why it happens
and we'll do it visually so it's as
intuitive as possible
no ridiculous hypotheticals no fluid
analogies
no historical fluff just geometry
let's do this
[Music]
this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
sure sure welcome to relativity the show
where everything is made up and the
measurements don't matter
all right stop right there this model is
real
it's been experimentally tested atomic
locks
in the iss particle accelerators
muons from space muons from
space the universe
looks different to different observers
and actually a
looks is an understatement the universe
doesn't just look different to different
observers
it is different to different observers
that's why we call it relativity
observers disagreeing about measurements
doesn't make those measurements fake
it just makes them relative say we're
looking out the window of my space
station at a couple identical rockets
one is at rest relative to us the other
is being flown by rocket clone they're
both identical
but the moving one is shorter that's
length contraction
so are they like physically compressed
well not
really stress compression is when the
atoms get closer together
that's not what i mean length
contraction is just when two observers
disagree
about how to measure length it's not an
optical illusion though
the rocket is shorter for one of the
observers
but rule number one of relativity says
no frame of reference gets priority
over any other frame of reference if
rocket clone
measures the length of their own rocket
it would appear normal
for them it's my space station that's
moving and therefore my space station
that's length contracted
measurements like length are relative to
the observer
and so is time it would look to us as
the rocket clone's clock is ticking
slower
we call that kinetic time dilation time
dilation caused by motion
according to rocket clone it's our clock
that ticks slower
the ideas in relativity are weird i'll
give you that
but they're very real and they actually
make a lot more sense if you just suck
it up and do the geometry
doing dynamics in space is fine but you
miss a lot of intuition that way
adding a time axis changes everything
this is a space-time diagram the rocket
is still moving directly to the right
in space that upward motion you're
seeing
is only through time if you've seen a
lot of my videos
you've seen diagrams like this before
they're very powerful
powerful space-time is what we call a
hyperbolic geometry
anyone's first exposure to hyperbolas is
usually with conic sections
it's what you get when you slice a cone
parallel to its height
on an xy plane the most basic hyperbola
would look something like this
x squared minus y squared equals one if
we include scaling factors for each
direction
we can tweak it a little but the basic
shape is always the same
any geometry that has that specific
pattern is called a hyperbolic geometry
the minkowski space time in special
relativity is a hyperbolic geometry
the x-axis is space and the y-axis is
time
this minus sign makes it hyperbolic
in fact these hyperbolas would be the
paths of something accelerating
just remember we've suppressed the other
two space dimensions
these accelerating rockets are only
moving left and right
not up and down the up and down
direction is time
not space you still with me okay
let's keep going anything stationary
follows a path
that lines up with the time axis
anything moving steadily
follows a straight path anything
accelerating
follows a hyperbolic path because
hyperbolic geometry
the axes are not absolute though these
belong to our space station but these
belong to rocket clone
notice how the time axis lines up with
his path now
different observers can and will
disagree about lots of measurements
because they take those measurements in
their own frame of reference
the angle that a path makes with the
time axis tells you the speed of that
thing
in that reference frame i repeat speeds
are measured as angles small angles are
slow
large angles are fast angles close to 45
degrees
are near the speed of light fast fast
wasn't this video supposed to be about
length contraction
yes yes we're almost there every
individual point on this diagram
is called an event grid lines that line
up with the space
axis are all the events that happen at
the same time
grid lines that line up with the time
axis are all the events that happen at
the same place
that last bit is going to be very
important because before we can
understand how length contraction
happens
we need to define length first length
is the space-time separation between two
events
that occur at the same time what
think about any length you've ever
measured you put some kind of ruler or
tape measure down
and you look at the markings the reason
that works
is because you have two events one on
each end of the ruler
and you're measuring them simultaneously
you do essentially the same thing if
you're measuring the length of a rocket
it's just that not everyone agrees on
which events happen
at the same time remember grid lines
that line up with the space axis
are all the events that happen at the
same time if two observers have
different space axes
they'll disagree on which events are
connected since the events that define
length have to be simultaneous they'll
disagree about length too
and space-time diagrams allow us to
predict what those lengths will be if we
measure the length of the rocket
we would use these two events because
for us those happen at the same time
if rocket clone measures the length he
would use these two events
because for him those events happen at
the same time
you can see right away the lengths are
different the real question is
how different well remember that speeds
are measured as angles
this angle is the relative speed between
us and the rocket
do some quick trigonometry and bam
you've got yourself a ratio
if we see rocket clone moving at 55 the
speed of light
he might measure a length of 20 meters
but we'll measure 16.7 meters
we see a contracted length
what about time dilation the geometry
works for that too
a time interval is the space-time
separation between two events that occur
at the same place
grid lines that line up with the time
axis are all the events that fit that
description
if two observers have different time
axes they'll disagree
on which events are connected based on
this definition of time intervals
that means they'll disagree about clocks
too so
let's say my clone's clock is at the
center of his rocket
we need two events these two occur at
the same place for him
but not for us we'll need to use these
two events
again these separations are obviously
different
the question is how different
using the relative speed and some trig
bam you've got a ratio
if we see rocket clone moving at 55
percent the speed of light
he might measure a time interval of one
minute but will measure 1.2 minutes
that's kinetic time dilation so you can
see now that
weird relativistic effects are just the
result of geometry
a hyperbolic geometry where speeds are
measured as angles
but a geometry nonetheless if two
different observers disagree on which
events happen at the same place and
which events happen at the same time
then they're going to disagree on just
about everything they'll disagree on how
long a rocket is
they'll disagree on how much time has
passed for that rocket
but it all makes sense in the geometry
of space-time
frankly it couldn't be any other way so
did that help you understand length
contraction a little better or did i go
too deep
let us know in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember
it's okay to be a little crazy if you
want to learn more about special
relativity
brilliant is a good place to start the
first section of their course on special
relativity has a quiz on length
contraction and time dilation
where you'll use lorentz transformations
to solve problems
later in the course you'll get a chance
to see the full power of space-time
diagrams in action
it's just one of over 60 interactive
courses in math science and computer
science that brilliant has to offer
their thought-provoking content helps
guide you to mastery by taking complex
concepts
and breaking them into bite-sized
understandable chunks
you'll start by having fun with their
interactive explorations
and over time you'll be amazed at what
you can accomplish
if this sounds like a service you'd like
to use go to brilliant.org
science asylum today the first 200
subscribers will get 20
off an annual subscription
[Music]
in our last video we talked about the
cmb in orbano kiro said
wait a minute isn't orange the new black
nope
technically speaking black is the new
orange
i'm such a dork anyway thanks for
watching
you